fans and friends were clearly devastated
to hear about the death of Power Rangers
actor Jason David Frank he is just a
small sample of how they mourned his
passing on social media Jason David
Frank's representative confirmed to TMZ
that the actor has died at age 49 and is
survived by his four children the news
of the Power Rangers icon's death has
come as a shock to millions of fans
around the world who tuned in over the
last three decades to see Frank's
portrayal of Tommy Oliver the character
first debuted as a green Ranger in
Mighty Morphin and Power Rangers the
first series in the Power Rangers
franchise in 1993. originally a villain
under the spell of Rita repulsa Oliver
later joins the titular team deciding to
use his powers for good what have I done
what you did you did on the reader's
influence
you own the power now while his
intentions were positive the Green
Ranger was sometimes rebellious causing
friction and clashing with his fellow
Rangers the character later achieved a
legendary status when he assumes the
role of the mythical white ranger
becoming the formal leader of the team
arguably the most popular and beloved
Power Rangers character of all time
audiences were fascinated with how Frank
added Nuance to an already tortured and
multi-faceted character it also helps
that Oliver's green ranger was he
epitome of cool in the early 90s with
young viewers obsessed with his Charisma
and a lone wolf mentality after Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers ended Frank
returned more than a dozen times as
Tommy Oliver in spin-offs becoming the
anchor character for the franchise he
even had a small cameo in the 2017
live-action film The star's final
appearance as a beloved green ranger was
in 2018's Power Rangers super Ninja
steel hoop better to destroy the real
Tommy Oliver than me
Take Your Best Shot generations of Power
Rangers fans have grown up watching
Frank as Tommy Oliver making the actors
lost all the more devastating as the
news of Frank's passing made his way
throughout various pockets of the
internet the Power Rangers fandom
couldn't help but emphasize and
celebrate the actor's Legacy one to the
user wrote there weren't too many that
inspired me as a kid but Jason David
Frank surely did you will truly be
missed but never forgotten you are the
Power Ranger echoing similar sentiments
another person tweeted just how unique
the character was pointing out how the
Green Ranger was a menace in his early
appearances causing new stresses for the
Power Rangers the fun continued man
great times watching this show as a kid
Jason David Frank made those memories
happen for me another fan tweeted I
can't believe this my childhood hero
from green with evil to the Power
Rangers movie a legend I'm lost for
words and send out my love to as friends
and family other users shared their
grief by celebrating his legacy one
listed off all the many colors of Power
Ranger Tommy had been tweeting the only
Power Ranger to be the White Ranger
black Ranger Green Ranger and red ranger
twice on the Power Rangers Fan subreddit
one user couldn't quantify the impacts
the Green Ranger had on popular culture
writing his legacy is immense the impact
he had over three generations of
children's lives is almost incalculable
iconic and Unforgettable while fans
continue to mourn the loss of their
beloved actor those who worked with the
Green Ranger on Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers also took the opportunity to
express their grief and discuss Frank's
Legacy Walter Jones who played the
original Black Ranger told TMZ he was an
inspiration to so many people his
presence will be dearly missed it's so
sad to lose another member of our Ranger
family Amy Jo Johnson who played the
Pink Ranger and Tommy Oliver love
interest took to Instagram to share a
selfie of the two sat at a fun
convention she wrote Jace you were
beautiful and truly unique my life just
won't be the same without your frenetic
hilarious caring driven and creative
ball of energy I will always love you
dear friend please rest now in peace
several celebrities from other corners
of the entertainment industry Express
their sense of loss as well minion
screenwriter Brian Lynch tweeted Jason
David Frank was quite literally the hero
for so many people even when Power
Rangers got a little corny he remained
super cool Evil Dead icon Bruce Campbell
also took to Twitter to remember how he
and Frank grew close while on the
convention circuit writing we enjoyed
the crappy coffee smoking Stogies on the
loading dock and dressing up in wacky
outfits Jason's loss is another reminder
to appreciate the ones you're with right
now
foreign
[Music]